diplômé de l'essec aurore le bond des
roches a commencé une carrière sans
surprise dans le conseil en stratégie à
la prose de la quarantaine la jeune
femme décide de voler de ses propres
ailes et rachète gauthier un atelier de
fabrication de tringle à rideaux sur
mesure j'avais envie de pérenniser un
savoir faire rare dans l'art de vivre à
la française
et j'ai découvert un univers que je
n'imaginais même pas exister la jeune
parisienne
un vrai coup de coeur pour cette
structure familiale elle allie la
tradition la technicité la technologie
l'esthétique tout ça avec une haute
exigence de qualité et puis voilà ces
essais thibault face à la concurrence
chinoise
gauthier dispose d'un atout de taille
son millier de paires modèle des moules
louis carzou louis saez dont raffolent
les riches étrangers
c'est père modèle il on
ils on s'entend ils sont tous avec une
marquage donc le numéro
larosace larosace 50 voilà un moule
donc on va faire une pour le reproduire
une fonte à la cire perdue
donc on va injecter le letton et ensuite
obtenir cela le prestige du passé mais
aussi la modernité
la pme chartraine est la seule au monde
à avoir développé ce concept de tringle
motorisés elle fonctionne avec une
télécommande dont la base est un tube de
laiton de diamètre 40 dans lequel on a
intégré un rail motorisés et du coup b
vous pouvez rester dans votre canapé
pour faire fonctionner l'ouverture ou la
fermeture du rideau
l'entreprise a été labellisé patrimoine
vivant il y a moins d'un an
le fait de l'avoir reçue on sait bien
qu'il n'y a eu aucun groupe de pression
quel qu'il soit et par rapport à cela
prend désormais les architectes et
décorateurs
vont vont savoir qu' on est entreprise
du patrimoine vivant
ils vont être de suite rassuré par
gauthier et compagnie du fait de ce
label une belle aventure humaine qui
conduit le petit atelier à équiper le
ritz le louvre et de nombreux palais à
l'étranger
[Musique]